[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down some of the creepiest
details in Midsomer the horror by re
aster is filled to the brim with
subliminal images hidden meanings and
metaphors that make the movie a real
trip to get through in this video we're
going to be breaking down some of the
creepiest details hidden in scenes that
not only foreshadow the pot but also the
mental stay of the characters there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to see the movie yet and
don't want anything potentially ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and please drop a like if you enjoy the
breakdown with that out the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
every creepy detail in Midsomer okay so
Midsomer has a lot of theme slice
throughout it there's grief breaking
free of a toxic relationship and finding
a new family Danny our central character
goes through all of this during the film
after the death of a sister and family
early on the entire plot of the movie
can actually be seen in a mural right at
the start that depicts the events of the
film it makes me want to take off my
crown and pronounce re Esther as the new
spoiler King you deserve it yes spoil
your whole movie this opens the film or
at least the director's cut vision but
please let me know if it's in theatrical
too as it bears a lot over the movie get
it bears never mind as you can see the
painting starts with death which is
meant to represent Danny losing her
family there are pipes connected to her
them and the figure of a skeleton that
represents the Grim Reaper next is the
grief in despair that Danny feels whilst
Christine tries to consult her also
checkout pail in the tree sketch in
there I'll get into that detail in just
a bit they'll then travel and are
greeted by the Hargis and Danny becomes
the May Queen the bear and people
falling from the cliff can be seen as
well as pail leading the group with a
flute in his mouth this is similar to
the Pied Piper who led a bunch of
children to well we don't know but it
shows that they are being strung along
by the character the painting also
represents the seasons of winter spring
summer and autumn this motif is very
much lace throughout the movie with
there being mentions of
life being divided into seasons through
the Hargis we learned that children
under the age of 18 are considered to be
in the spring section of their life ages
18 to 36 are considered to be summer and
this is the age bracket that the central
Casper into the film is also set in
summer hence the title and nurse this is
why we mainly focus on the group autumn
is classed as ages 36 to 54 and winter
is classed as 54 to 72 this is when the
elders of the group die and it's also a
transitional phase for them in which
they are meant to be reincarnated into
nature though this ceremony is centered
mainly around death we also know that
the hog race don't mind seeing death
outside of this as several characters
are sacrificed throughout the movie
Christina's sacrifice at the end of the
film after Danny takes up the May Queen
position and he stuffed into a bear and
burned alive this motif of a bear and a
queen can also be seen very early on in
the film when we see a picture of a bear
and a girl with a crown hanging above
Danny's bed this is a painting by John
Bower a Swedish artist known for making
art on Swedish folklore and mythology
just before Christian is told that he
can impregnate a member of the group we
also see an image of a bear being burned
alive he is placed in a chair directly
in front of it which means that he can
do nothing but look at it it's placed on
the wall against the room that he's
about to go into and this will be where
he decides to betray Danny or not he
tells him his fate however he does
nothing to avoid this and thus he is
paralyzed much in the same way that he's
paralyzed at the end of the film Pal
does say in the movie that his family
died in a fire and he was raised by the
Hargis it could be that they were
sacrificed when he was very young and
thus he ended up becoming adopted by
those in the village we see a scarecrow
dalsu on a bookcase during the movie and
another figure beside it this represents
the corpses that are stuffed with hay
and put beside christine at the end of
the movie when he's put into the bear we
can also see a picture of the Scarecrow
from The Wizard of Oz and this
iconography is laced throughout the film
at one point we can see that Danny has a
painting of two moons in a room
symbolizing an almost endless night for
her juxtaposing this the days of the
festival are almost non-stop and this
contrast shows the difference
between her two lives upon entering the
festival there's a big Sun doorway and
also a Sun painted onto the central
platform which indicates the two suns in
the area we spend a moment with Danny's
family in the film and you can see by
their bedside that there's a picture of
Danny that has a crown of flowers above
it this shows that it was always her
destiny to travel this path though
Danny's parents died in the first act
they actually returned later in the
movie when she's crowned and can be seen
as members of the crowd Danny's sister
horn said throughout the movie and she
appears behind her at one point in a
mirror when she's having a bad trip it's
a blink in you'll miss a moment but it's
definitely there Danny's sisters face
can also be seen in the trees after the
ritual and the image of her sucking on
an exhaust pipe is superimposed into the
surroundings showcasing that the grief
Danny feels is in the area and this is
forced her to take the path with the
group now personally I take this as her
being haunted by the fact that she could
have actually saved her parents when we
first see them they are visibly
breathing showing that at the start of
the movie they were alive Danny in the
opening is hysterical but instead of
phoning the police she phones Christian
he tells her that it's nothing and that
she's overreacting had she not listened
then she likely could have saved her
parents lives and thus she
subconsciously hates Christian and
looking at whether there had been other
faces spotted in the movie I did come
across some post that said there was one
in the snow out the window at the start
however I wasn't able to find this this
also meant to be wandering the airplane
scene but again I couldn't spot this
apparently if you line up the smashed
head of the person that jumps off the
cliff you can see that the islands in
the face are similar but I can't really
see it here even when I lay them out on
top of each other now speaking of the
cliff jumping scene there are what looks
to be faces in the rocks behind the
group I don't know whether this is for
Daphne but it's something that struck me
when watching the movie Danny finds a
new home with the Hargis and this is
exemplified in several motifs and at
many points in the movie throughout the
majority of midsummer Danny's clothes
are all really baggy and they don't
really fit it the first outfit that
doesn't hang off her is the dress made
for her at the village and this
cases that she fits in better with them
than everyone else hell gives Danny a
picture that he sketches of her and he
tells her that it's something that he
only does on birthdays when Danny is
pronounced as the May Queen he two draws
one for her signifying her new birth
Danny and Christina in their
relationship pretty much go around in
circles
refusing to end it with one another even
though they're both then happy towards
the climax of the movie Danny dances
around in a circle as part of the May
Queen ritual this cyclical behavior
represents the constant spinning of
their relationship that is continuously
going around in circles and getting
nowhere Danny is becoming exhausted by
this however she manages to break free
and in the same moment gets away from
Christian Danny has pronounced the May
Queen whilst Christian cheats with Maya
Maya rearranged is of course may hats
off if you spotted that one may seduces
Christine with a love potion and the
recipe for this is actually showcasing a
painting even down to the hair in the
food lovely that wish the wife would do
that for me
when the potion or rather spell is being
put over Christian we can see that his
drink is a completely different color to
the rest of the group showing that
something has been added to it now
judging by the hints in the movie this
is blood women lis blood that the only
women get I'll leave that up to you
imaginations what that is anyway when
Danny catches Christian cheating she
cries out loud and a group of women
ritualistically sob with her this
contrast is sobbing that she does with
Christian who doesn't really seem to
react or care at all this happens at
several points are the movie and they
seem very distant emotionally with
Christian having little empathy for her
however here there is a shared empathy
that shows she has more in common with
them at one point he tries to light a
candle for her but he can't this
metaphorically shows that they are
struggling to give their quote unquote
flame alive and it shows the
deterioration of their relationship the
ha gasps initially start off in all
white clothing however throughout the
film they start to gain color most
notably red which indicates the blood
that has been shed for the festival the
are rune that appears during the movie
at several points translates to a
journey growth or evolution which is
what many characters go on throughout
the film the death rune appears on
Christians
clothing marking him for sacrifice and
letting us know that he doesn't have
long left the carpet did the shining
pattern is often lace throughout films
and you may have also noticed it in
several movies however in midsummer it
appears it's Danny's blanket and it's a
nice little note to that horror classic
I'm sure there's a lot more going on but
for the meantime that's our entire list
I really want to re-watch the film just
to see if there's anything that I missed
but after three watches those were the
main things that I spotted now obviously
I loved hear your thoughts on midsummer
and if there are any other scary details
that didn't make the list comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of all the times that
Pennywise was hidden in the background
of a scene in a chapter 1 & 2 we go over
all of the hidden appearances so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show in the follow us at definition
YT click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
you can win the Star Wars Skywalker saga
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the one that's gonna be chosen
at random on the 15th of April and the
cell be shipped out from then - ever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]